according to dana milbank donald trump
held a super spreader event at the white
house and got coveted 19 himself this by
the way is now the great sin if you get
covet 19 yourself this means that you
are a sinner of some unforgivable sort
which is gonna be really weird because i
would assume at some point some people
in the white house like say jensahi
would get kova does that mean that she
was some sort of evil character
dana milbang says he praised cue anon
adherents embraced violent white
supremacists waged a racist campaign
against black lives matter demonstrators
remember according to
it's as though
you spit into a computer a thousand dana
millbank columns and a dana millbank
column popped out the other end
right the ai actually came up with this
column
trump got press coverage as favorable as
or better than biden is getting today
sure biden has had his troubles with the
delta variant afghanistan and inflation
but the economy is rebounding
impressively he's assigned major
legislation he has restored some measure
of decency calm and respect for
democratic institutions has he has he
though dana are you sensing a sense of
of calm and decency from this white
house
are you respecting uh how about respect
for democratic institutions you got the
white house ripping on the supreme court
every single day you have the democrats
in congress talking about killing the
filibuster you have the democrats
talking about completely rewriting the
bargain between the american citizen and
their government you're talking about
the federal government cramming down vax
mandates on 80 million employees across
the united
i feel like the restoration isn't going
all that well
but here's the point for the media
it doesn't matter what joe biden does
joe biden ought to be treated with kid
gloves because he is a democrat
and so according to dana milbank the
real threat here is the media are being
too kind to the authoritarians he says
we need a skeptical independent press
but how about being partisans for
democracy the country is in an
existential struggle between
self-governance and an authoritarian
alternative and we in the news media
collectively have given equal if not
slightly more favorable treatment to the
authoritarians
yes that's right i'm sure that the media
dana milbank have been very favorable to
the authoritarians like donald trump at
the expense of joe biden it's been very
rough for joe biden it's not that he's a
president it is that the media have been
on the side of donald trump and the
authoritarians according to dana melbank
unbelievably enough the media are kind
to donald trump but mean to joe biden
now this is the last vestige of people
who are desperate to save joe biden
considering that he's just a really
really bad president but it's going to
tie into the narrative that we're going
to see over the next couple of years
right the narrative that we're going to
see all the way up to 2024 because they
tried it in 2020 and it kind of sort of
worked just because donald trump is such
an outrageous character that the media
were able to pin on him pretty much
everything and donald trump committed
one of the cardinal sins of politics hey
the way that you win in politics is you
make it very difficult to vote for your
opponent you make it very easy to vote
for you donald trump makes it difficult
to vote for his opponent and very easy
for people to vote against him
he makes it hard for people to vote for
him right that's the story of 2020.
in 2016 he made it very difficult to
vote for hillary clinton he made it hard
to vote for him but people just hated
hillary more by 2020 by 2020 that math
had shifted a little bit he made it very
easy democrats and the media are now
going to try out the same playbook on
republicans so right now it's very
difficult to vote for democrats
democrats have done a horrible job
running the country
they're in control of the senate they're
in control of the house they're in
control of the presidency and we have
seen a stagnating economic response to
the pandemic we have seen calls for a
new lockdown we've seen complete foreign
policy collapse in afghanistan we're
seeing additional chaos in the
international scene which we'll get to
in a moment and so the media are left
with the same narrative that they tried
out in 2020
and this narrative of course is that
america is a white supremacist place and
republicans are representative of that
underlying white supremacism okay good
evidence of how media coverage actually
operates for example is the coverage of
a white nationalist march that happened
in washington dc by a group called
patriot front okay now i've never heard
of this group because why would you hear
of this group it's not a particularly
large group it's not a group of people
who have a major impact in the american
public debate but basically a bunch of
white supremacists decided to rally
in washington dc
and apparently this was worthy of
coverage by places like the daily beast
by places like the washington right like
like the fact is you needed national
coverage of the of the white supremacist
rally that happened in front of the
lincoln memorial according to the daily
beast a group of white supremacists
stormed through downtown stormed
through downtown washington dc on
saturday evening bearing american flags
mildly menacing plastic shields while
marching to the beat of a snare drum
down the steps of the lincoln memorial
but after chanting aggressively about
their plans to reclaim america their
intended show of force stalled
spectacularly when they lost their ride
while the group had marched through the
city with threatening chance about their
plan to reclaim america by the end of
the night it was not even clear how they
intended to reclaim their u-haul
the rally by more than 100 members of
the patriot wow 100 people
ah boy howdy they're probably going to
overthrow the democracy of those hundred
people held just blocks from the white
house sparked fear among many bystanders
immediately attracted the attention of
law enforcement who shadowed the group
to apparently prevent any clashes from
erupting
members wore uniform white gators
sunglasses blue jackets khaki pants
brown boots and hats some donned plastic
shin guards seeming to anticipate
violence
the patriot front leader thomas rousseau
spoke beside the capitol reflecting pool
bystanders booed asked about the reason
for the march russo said our
demonstrations are an exhibition of our
unified capability to organize to show
our strength not as brawlers or public
nuisances but as men capable of
illustrating a message and seeking an
america that more closely resembles the
interests of its true people no arrests
were made
uh apparently the cops just kind of
stood around waiting for these people to
leave
two dozen members of the white
supremacist group could not leave they
were apparently stranded members of the
group had waited in a one-way roundabout
to depart in one of the u-hauls they'd
used to transport themselves but the
large rented moving van could not fit
them all so many of them were forced to
wait in 45 degree darkness as the bulky
orange vehicle made multiple trips of
the over the course of the nearly three
hours
patriot front used to be called vanguard
america okay so
why exactly is this relevant the reason
it's relevant is because this actually
received fairly widespread media
coverage
okay this this is a story that deserves
basically no media coverage because
here's the reality when 100 people rally
for anything that is not a big story
when you have when you have 100 people
rally for like i can get a hundred
people to do pretty much anything in the
united states a country 330 million
people kept this received fairly
widespread media coverage and the
question is why why would white
nationalists go viral on twitter like
100 of them marching by the lincoln
memorial
and the answer is because this ties into
a broader democratic narrative so when
you talk about dana milbank the coverage
of joe biden versus donald trump you
have to understand that it is not merely
the coverage directly of who the
president is that matters it is the
coverage of all the issues in the united
states that directly impact politics so
when you make it seem in the united
states for example that there is a grave
white supremacist threat which is
exactly the case that was being made by
many members of the media last year
when you make that case over and over
and over and meanwhile you suggest that
anyone who opposes black lives matter is
in fact a white supremacist
the movement in the group is in fact a
white supremacist they're not just
opposed to riots and looting they're
white supremacists if you if you believe
that
then this makes you a bad person right
that sort of narrative drives how
politics is done in the united states
and you're seeing the media re-up this
right they're re-upping this in time for
2022. again the broader democratic
narrative which they tried out in 2020
and it worked for them was the idea that
america was under true authoritarian
threat from the right and that was
exacerbated in the aftermath of the
november election by donald trump
talking loosely about the evils of the
election and suggesting the election had
been stolen from him and then it was
exacerbated more gravely by january 6 in
the media claiming that we were just
moments from a coup attempt
okay and now the democratic through line
is that if you oppose black lives matter
in 2020 if you oppose the riots in the
looting if you thought it was a lie that
america's police are systematically
racist or more broadly that america was
systemically racist this means you are
part of the authoritarian white
nationalist movement that was the line
they used in 2020. then they moved that
through january 6 which they said was a
white nationalist uprising that was just
moments away from seizing the country
and now they're moving that into the
halls of congress so you have ilhan omar
trying to make the case that lauren
bobert and margery taylor green are true
threat to the united states and so of
course is kevin mccarthy because they're
being mean to ilhan omar hey now here's
the thing about ilhan omar she's a
terrible human being ilhana omar is in
fact an advocate on behalf of terrorists
in the past she literally wrote a letter
to a judge that judge
was being asked to rule on the case of a
man from minnesota who was trying to
join isis she wrote a letter to the guy
saying that he was just a victim of the
american system and so the judge should
go easy
on him this is ilhan omar who voted
against iron dome funding for israel
which is a solely protective technology
that prevents hamas missiles from
hitting the interior of israel elena
omar
sympathizes with terrorist groups like
hamas
okay against israel
omar is a terrible member of congress
now none of this means that people
should be sending death threats to
anybody because this is a free civilized
country in which you should be able to
express your opinions without fear of
death threats death threats are illegal
for a reason okay but ilhan omar is now
saying that if she receives criticism or
if somebody makes an untoward joke about
her that this is just the threat to
american democracy writ large and
democrats are going to try and trot out
this playbook so while dana melbank
claims that the media are upholding
authoritarianism by me by being mean to
joe biden
the reason he means that is because many
members of the media think the same they
believe that the narrative in american
politics is that the democrats are the
good party and the republicans are the
white nationalist evil party and they're
going to do whatever they can to afford
that story
here is here is ilhan omar making this
case on state of the union
what is it like to hear that kind of
blatant bigotry
blatant islamophobia coming from a
fellow elected member of the house of
representatives
it's shocking and unacceptable
um and you know it's very unbecoming of
a congresswoman
to use that kind of derogatory dangerous
um
uh
inciting language
against a colleague many of us thought
you know post 9 11 that we were on the
men's
many of us thought since not a lot you
mean since something happened to some
people said that that 9 11
congresswoman omar
okay but again this is part of the
broader narrative now here's the thing
here's the thing when you watch those
white nationalists march on the steps of
the lincoln memorial and there are 100
of them and they can't even get
organized enough to get a u-haul out of
town does that seem like a threat to the
system to you
did it really seem like we were on the
verge of being overthrown on january 6th
last year or did it seem like a bunch of
drugs and idiots decided to invade the
capitol building get themselves arrested
and then spend the next year in jail
because it seemed a lot more like the
latter to me that doesn't mean that
donald trump said good things between
the november election and january 6 he
did not i was highly critical of it you
can go listen to it
it does not mean that the people of
january 6 were not a threat to life and
limb to some police officers because
they did some physical damage to some
police officers they harm people and
they should go to jail for that
what it does mean is that if you're
looking at the systemic power in the
united states the systemic power in the
united states is behind the opinion of
people like dana milbank
and dana milbank is is
openly acknowledging what many in the
media believe which is their job to
protect democrats from the vicissitudes
of fortune it is their job to protect
democrats from the reality of their own
rule because if we expose the american
public to how bad they are their jobs
the authoritarians might take over now
the reality is that the true
authoritarians in american life the ones
who have institutional power backing
them are the people who are talking
about shutting down your daily life
because of an omicron variant that by
the way is almost certainly less deadly
than delta
the people have control over your daily
life are the people who want more
control over your daily life
the supposed white nationalist
authoritarian threat to the united
states is not from the right
the racist threat to the united states
on a cultural level is from people who
advocate on behalf of a 1619 project
that pushes the notion that if you are
white in the united states you carry
some sort of race guilt
based on the color of your skin and that
if you're black in the united states
you're inherently a victim of the system
that is a message not echoed by a fringe
crazy few that is that is a message
echoed by nearly everyone in the
mainstream media
remember ilhan omar is sitting there on
state of the union having retained her
spot on the house foreign affairs
committee talking about why lauren
bobert should lose her minority
committee assignment because lauren
bobert made an ill-advised joke about
ilhan omar carrying a bomb in her
backpack meanwhile illinois is an open
raging anti-semite and the democrats
have repeatedly led her off the hook for
it
and the media still have ilhan omar on
to talk about what a victim she is in
american society and how american
society is deeply racist
so which side actually has the institut
in order to actually effectuate a coup
you have to actually have the power you
have to have some institutional power to
back you you can't effectuate a coup
with a bunch of idiots from your local
drinking club
to effectuate a coup you have to have
some sort of institutional support the
institutional supports in the united
states are all on on behalf of a left
that mirrors the priorities of dana
milbank and he knows this which is why
he's attempting to shame everybody on
the on the media left into joining his
crusade not to honestly cover the biden
administration
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang